在13年的时候结了婚，
一九年的时候就已经领了，
分手的理由是男方外面有人，
这个在离婚协议书上也有说明，
但是当时孩子才两三个月，
总之就是我们虽然有这个证，
但是后面的这些年里，
其实我们实际是在一起生活的，
进去的话呢，
实在是生活不下去了，
在大概两个月之前吧，
当时的抚养权是判决给我的，
约定给我的，
然后呢，
离婚协议上有写他每个月支付5K的抚养费，
当然这个他并没有支付，
因为后面毕竟我们生活在一起嘛，
现在的话呢，
在大概两个月之前，
我决定就是脱离他呢，
我给了他10个W，
之外的话呢，
还有一些其他的约定的东西，
抚养权是公证处已经公证了，
把抚养权变更给他了，
但是现在两个月之后，
他不想要孩子，
他想去甩院再把抚养权起诉到我的身上，
他的理由是什么呢？
因为我现在每个月收入只工资的话大概是7K，
他的话呢，
他一直是做那种就是零散的收入，
他是没有一个合理的收入证明的，
那他如果去起诉的理由应该是他没有能力抚养孩子，
但是我有，
我就想问一下这种情况我该怎么办？
我为了孩子和他过了这么多年，
现在我要开始我的生活，
而且是这样，
就是孩子的奶奶，
就是能力。
非常的钱，
他大概每个月能挣六七个W左右，
但是他也是那种代理记账，
就是他也没有那种很合理的收入证明，
所以我觉得孩子跟据男方是对他以后的发展更有利的，
这也是我为什么这些年一直在和他生活的原因，
我就想问，
如果他现在去起诉法要大概会怎么？
他一般情况下变更孩子抚养权起诉通常是我想要，
你不给我，
我去起诉你，
很少有这个工作，
孩子在我这儿，
我不想要，
我去起诉你，
我不给你，
这个很难实现，
如果他真的去了，
那我要做的就是线下找一个向您同职业的人，
然后我去应对，
对吧？
孩子多大了，
5岁半，
男孩女孩儿很好，
就是他去起诉我的这个点，
因为他可以随时起职嘛，
他那种灵活职业，
他如果去起诉他的点只有一个，
就是他认为他没有能力生养孩子，
但是他看上我的工司，
他认为我有能力，
这个点也不太成力是吧？
这也不好说，
法官手上的自由裁量权是很大的，
我是说如果啊，
法官看到孩子在他手里，
他又打孩子，
又虐待孩子，
又饿着孩子，
这有能力你又怎么怎么样，
咱们就是说把法官当成一个正常人来看待，
法官会考虑对于孩子来说怎么安排，
于他而言很安全，
很健康，
说白了就是矮子面拔将军，
如果爹妈都不想要是吧，
如果他真的去做了，
我觉得像他如果就是面对法官有这种表。
这样的话，
我觉得我很难，
也说我也不要，
那我大概会接手过来，
那如果我接手过来的话呢，
那抚养费的问题又来了，
他没有工作，
那我就没办法要求他支付抚养费是吧？
是抚养费这个事情啊，
不是说看他现在没工作，
法官也得去权衡一下，
比如说以前他干什么工作的，
他大概收入是什么样子的，
或者说他是什么专业毕业的，
同一个专业毕业的大概收入是什么样子的，
或者说是他是以前是干什么行业的，
同一个行业的大概收入是什么样子的，
法官也会考虑这个不是说他上来说我没工作，
法官就判啊，
不给抚养费，
不是的，
因为好多人他是没有正经单位的，
对不对，
好多人他是自己搞小手艺的，
包括像这种没有正经单位的这个手艺的，
难道他就不给抚养费吗？
不是的，
法官会考虑他以前是干什么的，
他是什么行业的，
这个行业大概平均收入是什么样的，
就举个例子吧，
他如果以前是刮灰的，
那法官就会考虑一下这个正高刮灰的这个行业啊，
大概一年能挣多少钱，
明白了吧？
那如果他是搬砖的，
那法官要考虑一下这个搬砖大概一年能挣多少钱，
是这个意思啊，
好，
那我明白了。